- I learned over time
that you have to create
your own boundaries.
People aren't just gonna give them to you.
- Oh, lord.
- And it's okay.
Yeah, I need a whole show
about boundaries, y'all.
It ain't my forte.
(Khloe laughs)
- It's not so many people's fortes,
but you have to learn to...
It to feel not so guilty demanding them,
because it's sad that
you have to say a demand,
but it turns out to be,
'cause everybody wants a piece of you.
But I think the most important person
that deserves a piece of
you would be your babies,
and you have to give them that
and it's okay to demand that.
And I think anybody will understand
when it comes to your children.
- Absolutely.
It's interesting though,
I wish I would've learned
how to have better boundaries
though before children,
'cause now it is a good out to be like,
look, this is my kids and they get,
everybody kinda understands that,
but before you have kids
and you're like just single,
rocking it in an industry,
and trying to make it or any industry,
it's okay to say like, I'm
tired, I need a minute.
Like, but it's almost awesome
when you do have kids,
'cause you're like, look,
I really need a minute,
and people see like
something physically there,
but I wish people...
I wish I had learned that
sooner when I was younger.
I was not good at that.
- Yeah, and I agree.
I think when I was
younger before I had kids,
I felt so guilty to...
Like I wasn't almost worthy
- Me too.
of having a boundary 'cause
I didn't have a real reason.
That sounds so strange,
but that's almost how I felt,
like, oh, no one's gonna really care
about what my boundary is,
'cause I don't have a real responsibility
or something that I need to get home to.
But you do.
Self-care is a good enough reason.
Just because you're tired
or you need a break,
that's valid enough for a boundary.
And I don't know if
it's just 'cause of age
or I just was insecure or whatever,
I just didn't feel it was okay
to use that as my boundary.